the reason men should spend plays when
we talk about spin plates dating on
exclusively is you know for a lot of
guys it's very important to
[Music]
be able to have that level of savviness
and confidence around women so it's
something that you know a lot of men
don't even dream about this and and
being and you know dating
non-exclusively and dating multiple
people at a time is a
female dating strategy in the modern you
know world not something that a lot of
men will do you know women are
celebrated for it men are shamed for it
um even though it really is you know
quite the inverse of our natural mating
strategies and the way they've been for
hundreds of thousands of years so
spinning plates for man does a couple of
things it gets you to experience variety
which is very helpful
[Music]
um
it protects you from over investment
because if a plate falls off or you stop
seeing a woman there's always one to
take the place or you can go find new
ones
um it's not all about just you know
having random sex with a bunch of
different women it's not all about just
hey you know what I've got all these
girls on rotation I don't care about any
of them there's a lot of misconceptions
when it comes to you know the idea of
spinning plates and dating
non-exclusively and that's part of it
and they think that it's oh you need to
be a man you need to commit to one woman
and you don't need to be playing with
their emotions and things like that and
Jared and I for for years now have had
great relationships with a multitude of
different women and simultaneously you
know have had relationships going on and
a lot of times they know about each
other and a lot of times they're cooler
with it than they are not so
there's there's kind of this dichotomy
that I see sometimes and I've seen a lot
lately where guys will think either
you're settled down you're monogamous in
a relationship LTR with one woman or
you're just banging indiscriminately and
you don't care about any women in your
life because you're not settling down
and spinning plates and being able to
date not exclusively is the sort of
happy medium where you get to experience
variety you get to work on your skills
with women it makes you better with
women and also
fine-tunes you to female nature because
if you only have one woman that you're
dating your sample size is one
so you know if you're dating three four
five women at a time you can kind of see
what works you can see what doesn't you
make a mistake with one cool then then
another one can replace right away so
it's an absolute imperative strategy for
men that have a history of juanitis
maybe they went through a divorce uh
they were married for a long time or
very long long long LTR
it's one of the more important things
that men need to experience at any time
in their lives and I don't think any man
can really know what he wants and
experience happiness with a woman until
he has experienced abundance with women
um and we talk about it all the time you
know cream rising to the top and why
that's so important
so you know just keeping keeping three
or four women at a time
um not over investing in any of them and
you sort of make you cut you sort of you
know
March all of them through a natural
progression and some will fall off and
some will stay with you and then the
longer they stay on and the more they
sort of comply with with the way you
want to live your life and they're
willing to stick around the longer
they'll stay
yeah I think I largely agree with uh
that assessment there muff I'm actually
going back to your show and listening to
the the backlog of some of the episodes
that that I may have missed when I was
traveling for a long time and now I'm
kind of in a mini monk mode and one
thing I notice and you and I say it all
the time when we collaborate that you
can tell the guys that have experience
with women just really based on the way
they interact with women and I've seen
time and time again women go on your
show that a lot of times they come on
their their pit they're completely
pissed off and by the end of the
exchange there's a guy who hangs out
with a lot of women I can tell like
they're definitely attracted to you and
I think I left you a comment on on the
last one I popped on I was like yeah
that's exactly how you talk to a woman
she was going through some trouble her
man she could not rely on him she he
wasn't the rock she needed him to be and
she in real time leaned on you and you
kind of walked her through what was
going on and you could you could feel
the relief in the room albeit digitally
mediated by a stereo app that that's
what she was looking for and you gave
her exactly that at the time emotional
Outlet she needed and you can tell most
guys aren't able to do that they don't
have that skill set and mirroring what
you said it goes back to getting in your
reps getting in the experience I know
that we have the argument like uh last
time we did this show in person or
called in so I knew it's all about notch
count like well no it's it's not but
it's really just about the experience
and as you get more experience granted
that that number is going to go up and
the way I do the the plate spinning
thing uh we were talking in the pre-show
that it does get exhausting after a
while to be able to find whatever that
structure looks like for me I like
having two or three regular chicks one
uh one main girl but over the years I've
noticed that a lot of my relationships
they turn into mltrs which are multiple
long-term relationships and I actually
prefer that uh I love it when guys come
come in they say oh I've been married
for unhappily for 30 years and I'm not
getting any bedroom love and what Jaren
what makes you think you know about
women I've been in multiple
relationships for multiple years and
each one of those relationships is
better than the any relationship I ever
had when I was doing the two-way
monogamy model so it really depends on
how you want to stretch your life do you
define it an mltr like what are the
prerequisites what conversation do you
have to set that up just so the viewers
understand
for me it's the girl that I make
priorities so usually like I'm currently
spitting plates I'll have a girl come in
and she just kind of blows blows your
socks off uh not necessarily in just the
physical attractiveness department but
there has to be something else there
like you both kind of mesh for me it's a
compatibility thing availability and
compatibility compatibility are huge so
Friday night like hey I've got this
podcast early tomorrow morning I don't
really want to go out uh here's what my
night looks like and oh that would be
perfect and then she shows up not only
is she attractive but she also has
something to say and you get to talk and
you get to know in each other and you're
like all right we're kind of on the same
page in a lot of areas so that's for me
I'll make a mental checkpoint that um
give this girl extra attention not go
out of my way to do it but uh granted if
she is receptive then then I'll make her
more of a priority and that is every
relationship has a shelf life so that is
until she she screws it up but I I don't
decree the the main girl at some point
it just kind of happens it's the girl
that I prefer to hang out with because
she checks more boxes than just the the
bedroom fun department and it just kind
of ends up happening and they can they
can usually feel it too it's really guys
you've dated a lot of girls it's really
cool when you meet a girl and like you
both kind of realize like all right like
we both get it we're both on the same
page and uh those girls take a higher
priority in my life than any of like
your you know you're seeking chicks that
are just looking for a paycheck even if
you run your salt game you know at some
point they're probably out there still
trying to get money from dudes and
return for intimacy or inevitably their
their lower income Lower Class Type
girls and something will happen because
they don't have their life structured in
a healthy manner some something stupid
will come up and they will hit you up so
you always kind of have that in the back
of your head but with the the main girls
really my main girls to me it's just
it's kind of like my girlfriend
um it's the relationship actually feels
no different than what I would have
considered a girlfriend back when I was
doing the one minute one-way monogamy
model however now I can do to that with
multiple girls and I find when there is
competition anxiety or when girls I
don't ever throw them in each other's
face but when they do know about each
other you get the best out of them and
that that model seems to work very well
for me at this chapter in my life yeah
that's one of the things that you'll
that you'll discover is that I mean if
there's
if there's options that you can exercise
it it's kind of an easy way to keep her
in check because she misbehaves and she
knows you have other options
um a soft next is inclusive with you
leaving and going over the other girl's
place right so you know I know that
something makes her more invested too
when she knows you have options yeah I
know that some people get like really
bent out of shape you know with that
like that dude did a couple weeks ago
when we did the show
um you know the guy that was all about
his uh relationship with God dude
um you know because if he could do it he
would though that's what I always say to
those guys that's the truth though you
know it's the truth and you know to be
honest with you when you talk to like
like the real Biblical dudes they're
like that's kind of the way that it is
right like this is the way you know sort
of think that's that's the way that they
had it done
um you know it's only in modern times
where they've severed that tie it seems
from Men's innate nature
um which is
um abundance and variety
um so from my point of view and you know
you guys know that I'm an LTR are um I
don't uh I don't date or use dating apps
or spin plates anymore this is
I did all that
um I don't think it's changed that much
and I'll be honest with you like I think
if you want an honest up-to-date version
of what things look like today
definitely have a conversation with ma
for Jaren on that because you know
they're in the game daily sort of thing
but it's like
it's simple you know I talked about it
my book as well you know from my own
experience you know go out there
um you know make your connections date
do it simultaneously in a non-monogamous
fashion go about your life put yourself
first make yourself your own mental
point of origin do your thing Chase
Excellence be captivating be interesting
pursue hobbies that you like form strong
connections with uh you know men that
are legendary or working on becoming
legendary like those are the things that
matter more than getting the girls and
at some point I think what most guys
find is and this was my experience
anyway there's going to be you know
women that'll be like well like where do
we stand I really take your Vibe you
know where is this going sort of thing
and that's when you can decide and not
you know after you know two three or
four or five dates or anything like that
maybe after you know four five six seven
months you know something like that
that's when you can basically be like
yeah okay well you know I think you're
right too you know you seem to take a
lot of my boxes off and then you can
decide what kind of relationship you
want to structure from that point when
she has Where Do We Stand talk but it's
incredibly important I keep saying this
and guys don't listen to this [ __ ] it
enough she has to bring up that where do
we stand talk right because if you want
it like
when a when a relationship ends it
almost always ends on her terms I mean
eight out of 10 times divorces are filed
by women right when when breakups happen
even in you know boyfriend girlfriend
type of scenarios it's usually her
leaving the dude so you better set up
the structure like you better structure
the relationship on your terms not on
her terms right so it so it begins on
your terms but it's but just understand
that if and when it ends which on a
bounce of probabilities are probably
well like nothing is permanent it's
going to be on her terms hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out